موجز الاخبار اهلا بكم افاد مراسل الجزيره
ان جنود الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ترافقهم
جرافات الهدم اقتحموا قريه دير عمار غرب
مدينه رام الله في الضفه الغربيه وشرعوا
في هدم منزل يعود لمواطن فلسطيني بحجه عدم
حصوله على ترخيص للبناء
اصيبت 52 فلسطينيا خلال مواجهه الليله
الماضيه شرقي نابلس بين شبان فلسطينيين
وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي التي توغلت
المنطقه ومخيم بلاطه لتامين اقتحام
مستوطنين ويهود متجددين قبل يوسف لتاديه
صلوات تلموديه وقال الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني ان طواقمه تعاملت مع عشرات
الاصابات بالاختناق وافاد شهود عيان بان
قوات الاحتلال تبادلت اطلاق النار مع
مسلحين فلسطينيين في المنطقه
رفعت الرقابه العسكريه الاسرائيليه الحضره
الاعلامي عما سمته حدثا امنيا خطيرا وقع
على الحدود الاسرائيليه اللبنانيه مطلع
الاسبوع الجاري وقال الجيش الاسرائيلي انه
قتل شخصا تسلل من لبنان متهما اياه
بالمسؤوليه عن تنفيذ تفجير بعبوه ناسفه
وقع في مفترق جد جنوب حيفا صباح الاثنين
واشار الجيش الاسرائيلي الى انه يحقق في
مسؤوليه حزب اللال اللبناني عن العمليه
واكد ضروره الاستعداد لحدث على جبهات عده
بين ايران
نقلت سفاره الروسيه في واشنطن عن السفير
الروسي اناطولي انطونوف قوله في تغريده ان
استهداف اي طائره روسيه في الاجواء
الدوليه يعد اعلان حرب على اكبر قوه نوويه
في العالم
نقلت محطه ام بي سي عن مسئولين امريكيين
مطلعين على التقارير الاستخباريه ان اعلى
المستويات في الكرملين اجازت التصرفات
العدوانيه لطائرتين الحربيتين الروسيتين
ضد المسيره العسكريه الامريكيه فوق البحر
الاسود غير ان مسؤولا نشر الى انه لا
قرائن لديه بان الاذن صدر عن الرئيس بوتين
نفسه
قال وزير الدفاع الامريكي لودو انه اجرى
اتصالا مع نظير الروسي سيرجيو بشان حادثه
مسيره الامريكيه وشدد اوستن على ضروره
التواصل بين واشنطن وموسكو ودع روسيا الى
تشغيل طائراتها العسكريه بطريقه امنه
ومهنيه على حد تعبير
نقلت وكاله الاعلام الروسيه عن الرئيس
السوري بشار الاسد قوله الى دمشق سترحب
باي مقترحات من روسيا لاقامه قواعد عسكريه
جديده او زياده عدد قواتها في سوريا كما
قال الاسد الذي يزور موسكو لاجراء محادثات
مع نظيره ان الوجود العسكري الروسيه في
بلاده ليس من الضروري ان يكون مؤقتا فخامه
الرئيس اهلا اطلقت كوريا الشماليه صاروخا
باليسيا جديدا صباح اليوم الخميس ورجحت
وزاره الدفاع اليابانيه ان يكون الصاروخ
عادرا للقارات ودعا رئيس الوزراء الياباني
عقد اجتماع لمجلس الامن القومي بينما
اجتمع مجلس الامن القومي في كوريا
الجنوبيه وحث رئيس كوريا الجنوبيه
على الحفاظ على حاله التاهب
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]